and
um what about love
we talked about money is ultimately a
mechanism by which you can uh
pave uh a moral path through life
uh you know to me one of the purest
expressions that is love broadly defined
for family for others for knowledge for
the world
it's basically an optimistic open view
to the world that
embraces all that is beautiful about
this world
so um do you think about love often
in in a personal sense romantic family
friendship and in the broad sense
about its value in in uh in a successful
life
yeah of course i'm blessed to have a two
and a half year old daughter
and um love is the word we throw around
you know it's like
i love these potato chips i love you man
i love you my daughter it's got so many
different
uh intensities i guess you might say but
um i don't know my intuition is that
it is something very fundamental to the
universe like if
again i know words undo it justice but
if we just
proxy love with selfless action
the whole damn universe is selflessly
acting right it's just unfolding
and um it may sound a bit hippy dippy
but my intuition is just that love is
the
core of it somehow um i don't have
anything to back that up really it's
just
in the way you're framing it it's making
me think
that uh love we're talking we talked
about
sort of meditation is
as opposed to thinking from an
egocentric perspective of you the
individual operating in this world
is allowing you to be empathetic towards
the world and thereby
think of the universe think of the world
acting through you
almost like uh accepting this notion
that uh
ideas have you you don't have ideas
right
that you're not existing in the universe
the universe is existing
through you it's just like like that's
that's what's selfless
in that context means it's like
embracing that thought
that's a weird thought it's a weird
thought that we're just here for a
little bit of time
these meat vehicles
receptacles and uh this much bigger
thing
is just using us
not in a malevolent way but just like
like a river flows
is using us to create more and more
beautiful things
yes yes more and more beautiful things
we are
the universe experiencing itself yeah
frankly right
so that's a trippy thought man that
in some sense the universe created us to
experience itself and we are the high
you know one of the highest forms of
beauty that nature has created right if
we just think one of the most
complex and adaptive thing we're a
reflection of nature and
another thing that comes to mind here is
that
dalio has this quote which is truth or
more accurately
an accurate depiction of reality is
necessary for any
good outcome so when we think that love
or value is primary i think that too
reinforces this thesis that
acting out of love or acting out of
proper moral action you're
best reflecting the fundamental nature
of reality therefore you're best
creating the best possible outcomes or
the things of the most beauty whether
that's your artistic expression
your children your business whatever it
is
and you know jordan peterson goes deep
into that where you have to listen to
that
sense of meaning in your life or you
might have some decision on paper that's
so great this way but your heart says no
your heart says otherwise
um i i've tried
to listen to my heart throughout and i
think i think that creates the best
outcomes
but nevertheless does it make you sad
that
you in particular robert
are gonna be dead pretty soon
uh as as uh we talk about scarcity one
of the certain things that
ensure this the uh the scarcity of the
human experience is the fact that you
you and your consciousness are gonna be
done they have a deadline
only time and bitcoin are absolutely
scarce
[Laughter]
i um i'm fortunate
that when i i guess i got started on
this philosophical journey
a bit when i was younger but i got into
musashi and sun tzu quite a bit uh
who wrote musashi wrote the book of five
rings uh
[Music]
sun tzu wrote the art of war and one of
the things that
i mean these guys were just absolute
beasts you know they lived and died by
the sword
and they were just very uh
great equanimity about all things in
life and i also found this kind of in
the stoic philosophy where they just
are very cool with everything
and uh one of the lines there is that
the way of the warrior is the resolute
acceptance of death
and so i've always tried to think about
that like of course i experience fear i
experience you know everything that
you do in a meat suit right like anxiety
and all the things but
i always try to have that higher order
view of myself and that
it's just a certain experience occurring
at a certain level
but it shouldn't override your kind of
highest order self
that's just resolutely accepted death
and that
this is your one play in life
so hopefully that propels me towards
proper action i think scarcity
cannot help but lead to something good
just like with this conversation sadly
must come to an end
the scarcity of it is what makes it
beautiful so robert this was uh
one of my favorite conversations uh
philosophically
and every other level just
the ideas and the way you express them
around bitcoin
around morality around money
has been really inspiring and really
educational and i'm glad you're out
there
fighting the good fight and i'm glad
you're wasting all of this time with me
it was really fun
and thank you for coming down to texas
and having some good old uh brisket
together this is uh this is really fun
man this is awesome
thanks for having me man
you